[Music]
Um well hello everyone um thanks for
coming to the session here today. My
name is Jonathan Larson and uh I run the
graph uh team at Microsoft Research. Um,
some of you may have seen our paper that
we actually released last year uh the
graphite paper or you might have seen
our GitHub repo uh that was out there
and uh has a lot of stars on it. Um when
we released this last year to our
surprise it got a lot of attention and
also it inspired many other offerings
that we saw that were out there as well
too. Um my favorites of course were the
ones that New Foratic
as well too. uh but uh there's been lots
of derivative work from it and today
though I'm not here to talk to you about
some of the things that have been I'm
here to talk to you about some of the
new horizons and the two things I really
want to leave you with here today are
that uh LM memory with structure is just
an absolutely key enabler for uh
building effective AI applications. The
second as we'll talk about a little bit
later in the talk as well too are that
uh agents of course paired with these
structures can provide something even
more powerful. And let me go ahead and
go back to the slide here. So today I'm
going to tell you about a couple things.
The first is actually showing you graph
as applied to a specific domain. In this
case, we're going to apply it to the
coding domain to look at enterprise
productivity uh in the coding space. The
second is we're going to take a look at
a new release that we are announcing
today. Uh we're actually having a blog
post on this tomorrow. Uh we have
benchmark QED just went open source as
well. And then I'll talk about some uh
new results that we've had on uh some
graph evolutions on a new uh technology
we've been working on called lazy graph.
I won't be going into the specifics of
how it works. I'll just be showing some
benchmarks and talking about some of the
ways you be able to access it soon. So
with that, let me go ahead and jump into
graph for code and tell you about how
we've been using graph rag to actually
help uh drive repository level
understanding. And I want to start first
with a little demonstration. Uh everyone
likes to watch little videos. So I'm
going to go ahead and hit play. And yes,
it's showing on the screen there. So,
this is a little a terminal based video
game that one of my engineers have put
together. It's a one where you jump over
obstacles and then you get points when
you jump over them and you run into
them, you lose points. And two important
things, though. First, the LM has never
seen this code before and it's small
enough for the human to know the ground
truth holistically because it's only
about 200 lines of code across seven
files. But it's complex enough that the
LMS's had a lot of troubles
understanding it if you just provide all
the code directly into the context
window. So with that as a background,
let's take a look at what happens if you
use typical regular rag over the top of
this. So if you're using uh one of the
tools that help analyze your code, this
is the type of answer you might get
back. And this is we ran this through
with a regular rag system. And we asked
it describe what this application is and
how it works. And just to read you
because what it says because it's too
small to read. The application is
designed as a game that is configured
and initiated through a main function.
The game leverages a configuration file
and has its main components such as the
game screen, game logic encapsulated in
separate classes and functions. Totally
useless. It just says it's a game.
That's there's nothing more to it than
that. Um, and it just put a bunch of
other craft in there. If you use
graphite for code over the exact same
codebase with the exact same question,
you get a much much better description.
This is just a very stark contrast to
get between the two. So, in the graphic
for code, it says, "The application is a
terminal-based interactive game designed
to run with a in a cursorbased terminal
environment. So far, not much better,
but this next line just kills it. It
features a player character that can
jump vertically, obstacles that move
horizontally across the screen, and a
static background layer. The game
controls via keyboard input,
specifically using the space bar to
trigger the player's jump action. So,
what this is showing you is semantic
understanding. So if you've read our
paper or used any of the um graphite
code base that we've put out there,
you've you'll know about the concept of
what we call local and global queries.
And so this is what we would call a
global query over top of the repository.
It requires understanding the whole
repository to answer that question
correctly. And we can see that it excels
at that. So one of the next things we
decided to do was well if I can answer
questions pretty well, can it maybe do
code translation? And so that was the
next thing that we aimed it at. So
taking the same codebase here, we took
on the challenge of taking this Python
code and then asking to translate it
directly into Rust. And let me show you
just how that actually works. Let me go
and play the video here. So we're going
to do is start off with um in VS Code
here, we're going to look at the four
source code files. Well, there's four
main ones. There's seven files total for
this game. These are the source Python
code uh files that we're working with
here. We're going to go ahead and run
those just to show you. Again, this is
the same game. So this is again the same
sidescroller game here. And then what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually take those source code files
and just put them straight into an LLM.
We're first not going to use graphite
for code. We're just going to take all
that source code because it's only 200
lines of code and put in some nice
prompts. We tried a wide variety of
these prompts and then try and see if
the LM could actually translate that
code holistically and all of its pieces
into Rust and actually just work out of
the box. And so this is actually the
translation happening there. Um we're
going to go ahead and copy the Rust code
that it generated. So it did generate
Rust code. I got have to give it credit
for that. But after it generated the
code and we reviewed it there. We went
and we tried to compile it and there's
problems everywhere. Doesn't work out of
the box. Uh so then we use graphite for
code again bringing structure and these
these graph structures to the codebase
there. We're going to just go ahead and
run the translate function on graphite
for code and it generates on its side
all these all these new Rust files that
you see are on the side there. I'm just
going to skip past it because I don't
want to bore you with clicking through a
bunch of Rust files. But once we
generated all these REST files, we can
go ahead and run those REST files on
Graphic for Code side of things. And
presto, we have a full video game
completely translated from Python now
working in Rust natively. But we didn't
want to stop there. The next thing that
we wanted to do was, well, that game is
kind of a toy example. It's like 200
lines of code. Let's go to a codebase
with 100,000 lines of code. And that's
what we did next. So we went to the Doom
codebase. It's about 30 years old. Now,
we did run a bunch of tests over the top
of this here first uh because I figured,
well, all the LLMs are trained on the
Doom codebase. I mean, it's it's going
to just know these things on natively
and automatically. So, we did a bunch of
tests with that. We actually figured out
while it knew the Doom Doom codebase, it
didn't know any of the specifics. So, if
you ask it to actually modify the Doom
codebase in any sort of meaningful way,
the LM models just fail again
completely. Um so then what we did next
was well if we can reason and understand
over top of this codebase 100,000 lines
of code 231 files um maybe we can
generate some new outputs that you
otherwise couldn't generate. So with
that we then immediately had to start
used it to start generating
documentation. So this is actually
showing a highle repository level
documentation. Again going back to the
concepts of graph we have local and we
have global queries. This is showing you
the global query results and so it's not
looking at the understanding of a single
file. This is looking at modules in
their entirety like across 20 30 files
and being able to actually give you
sense for like what's the sound system
inside of the video game and how does
that work but then you can still drill
down into what we would call the local
style queries and actually see the
individual files as well too. So then we
thought, well, this is kind of neat. We
can look at the documentation, but if we
can look at the documentation, we can do
Q&A. We can do code translation. Can we
maybe take this one step further? Do
feature development? So that's the next
thing I'm going to show you. So um, we
had a lot of, uh, video game players in
our office and we were kind of thinking
about like what would be a cool thing we
put over top of this Doom video game.
And someone me said, well, does you
can't jump in the original video game.
What if we added the ability for a
player to jump? And that's a complex
thing to add into Doom because it
requires multifile modification. And if
you try to use AI systems to do multi
modification, what it'll often do is it
will do a great job editing one of the
files and then completely break a bunch
of the other files in the process of
doing so. And then it that just rinses
and repeats and continually kind of you
end up with something that doesn't work
is what what you oftentimes run into.
And it's because of this lack of
understanding how everything fits
together. But again, this is where graph
can really help out. So with that, we
went ahead and this is, if you haven't
seen the Doom video game, this is
actually a little video of the original
Doom video game being played, just to
give you some context for what it was.
Then we used uh the new um GitHub
copilot coding agent that was announced
at Build and we wired it up directly to
a graphite for code. So we're going to
go ahead and create new issue. This is
pointing to the Doom codebase and we're
going to tell it add jump capability to
the player. We're just going to add a
couple sentences of description here and
then tell it to go. And then we're going
to assign it to that GitHub copilot
coding agent.
And then the next thing we're going to
do is we're going to then go ahead and
look at what's happening underneath the
hood. So this is actually the GitHub
copilot coding agent reaching out to
graph for code on the back end coming up
with a plan that's holistic and it's
approaching it from the top down. And
then this is really the m the aha moment
we have for us. It changed a whole lot
of files and it worked out of the box
where all the other agents that we had
tried completely failed on this task and
because it worked because of those
graphic structures that we were bringing
to bear and actually using those uh with
that. So then the end result was we were
laid with joy and jumping in doom
specifically. So uh that's kind of the
story of how we got to with that. So
with that um I do have another part of
the talk I'm going to talk about today
and that's also um five minutes to talk
about that one and that's benchmark QED
uh just shifting topics a little bit I
just showed you graph ragra is applied
to one vertical uh next I want to
specifically talk about um how do we
measure and evaluate systems like graph
how do we build systems to evaluate
those local and global quality metrics
and so for that today I'm announcing
benchmark QED this is available now open
source on GitHub so you can go ahead and
uh uh check it out at the link. We just
I think got it live last night. Um, and
there's three components to this. The
first is what we're calling auto Q. And
auto Q is focused on doing query
generation for target data sets. So, it
allows you to take a data set and then
generate queries for it. AutoE is the
evaluation using LLM as a judge to
actually then evaluate how those queries
performed on that said data set. Autod
is the third component and that really
focuses on data set summarization and
data set sampling. Let's jump into just
a couple of these in a little more
detail. So if you take a look at auto Q,
autoq is taking a look at the local and
global aspects. You can see that there
on the x-axis. On the y-axis, it's then
combining that against data driven
basically questions that are generated
based on the data itself or persona or
activity driven which is the second type
that we have there. Those are more
complex slick if you take on the role of
a person in that domain field and then
using that to generate questions. So to
show you a few of these sample
questions, I'm just going to choose a
couple here. This was built on an AP
news data set that was focused on like
medical type of events. And so a data
local question might be why are junior
doctors in South Korea striking in
February 2024? There's a lot of highly
specific information in this and I would
expect regular rag to perform very well
on this type of question. In contrast,
take an activity global question here.
It might be what are the main public
health initiatives mentioned that target
underserved communities. There is
nothing in that question that you can
really pivot on in terms of like
embedding or uh indexing that would
really work on it. You really have to
holistically know the entire data set.
And so this uh auto Q will help generate
questions across that whole spectrum
from local to global from data driven to
activity driven and give you these
categories of questions that you can
use. Now once you generate those
questions we can then start measuring
them using autoe which is the evaluation
platform that we released along with um
this as well too. So just to get show
you this in in practice and how it works
it use it gives you a composite score
for metrics. The first is
comprehensiveness diversity and
empowerment which if you're familiar
with our paper those are three original
ones that we used back in that one and a
new one that we also call relevance. And
so we actually did some comparisons uh
just to show you how this works on lazy
graph rag which is one of the newer
technologies that we've been working on.
And we compared it to vector rag on 8k
120k and million token context windows.
And we had a few takeaways from that.
The first is if you take a look at these
charts any bar that is above the 50%
mark uh gives um means that lazy graph
is winning in that benchmark against
those specific vector eggs. So, vector
egg blue here is 8K, 120K, and a million
token context windows. And it's winning
correspondingly at 92%, 90, and 91% of
the time against data local questions,
which is kind of a surprise because one
of the first things that we started
seeing is that laser graph was actually
providing dominant performance um across
the entire span of questions, whether
they were local or global. And we do
expect rag to be performing better on
local questions. And you can see that
from the fact that data local and the
data global there's a little bit of a
lift between these bars between the
global and the and the local ones.
Second thing we noticed is that the long
context window didn't really make much
of a difference. We were expecting that
maybe the long context windows might
give you a little bit of a um because
you have a better understanding towards
those global types of questions. But it
actually turns out that laser graph in
this case was still able to dominate
those metrics. And in fact, when it when
we ran the test, it's not on the slide
here, we actually found that lazy graph
was a tenth of the cost of what we saw
in the 1 million token context windows
as well too. So those are a couple
things to show there. Now, uh with the
last minute that I have, I did want to
address another thing too with lazy
graph. Um you may have read the blog
posts about it in November last year
when we first discussed it. Um it is now
uh officially being lined up for launch
in a couple products. Uh the first is
Azure local and so uh it will they just
announced at build that uh lazy graph
rag will soon be incorporated into their
platform for that. So you can actually
try it out for yourselves there and it's
also being incorporated into the
recently announced at build Microsoft
discovery platform tool as well. So if
you're not familiar with Microsoft
discovery it does graph-based scientific
co-reasoning and just to give you a
quick summary of it goes from hypothesis
experiment learning and knowledge. I'll
just play a quick like 5-second video
here. And the questions the answers to
the questions that you start coming back
to with on this are powered underneath
the hood by graph and lazy graph as well
too. So as you can see the co-pilot here
is generating the deep reasoning over
graph-based scientific knowledge. Those
graphs are being powered by uh graphagg
and lazy graph. So with that, I just
want to leave you with a couple
takeaways. And the first is just that
LLM memory structure, LM memory with
structure is just a really really
powerful tool uh to keep in your tool
belt. Um and the agents of course can
massively amplify this power. And if you
have any questions, I'll be outside if
you want to talk about any of this
further. Thank you so much for your
time.
[Music]